I always uh mention this. This was to me
it was such an obvious example of what
I'm talking about and it was a super
since the Super Bowl was coming up which
I was just informed about and I just
learned who's actually going to be in
the Super Bowl. One of the Super Bowls
and I want I shuddered to imagine what
we're going to see for this one. Maybe
that's why I really want to watch it.
But there was a Super Bowl, I think it
was a few years ago, and one of the
commercials, it was basically all it
showed was images of uh one person or
other washing someone else's foot. And
uh to say that they had a political uh
connotation is to put it lightly because
all the people who were on their knees
washing feet were trad white people,
Americans. And all the people having
their feet washed were a Muslim woman in
a hijab, an Indian man in a turban, a
migrant who just uh, you know, crossed
the border, a gay man, a trans man. And
then it just, it showed those images and
then finally said Jesus didn't preach
hate, he washed feet.
All right, there you go. That in a
nutshell is adormat Christianity in in
all its in its grandeur right there.
That commercial, okay? Which is
basically uh your job is to get on your
hands and knees and wash everyone's
feet. Never mind the context. Never mind
if what they're doing is right or wrong.
Okay? You just shut up and wash feet
because that's what Jesus expects out of
you. Okay? And as I hope you saw,
actually that's not the case. It's quite
the opposite. Sure you can love and have
mercy on that person but in no way shape
or form are you giving in to the sin
that they are promulgating and you know
telling them oh it's okay one of them
for example uh was a was it looked like
a a woman at an a young girl at an
abortion center and then and people are
protesting abortion center but one of
the good Christians is there washing her
feet quietly and meekly not judging okay
and like I said one is like a homosexual
character and Uh I don't know who's
washing his feet. Okay. And uh sorry.
Okay. So that that right there is
exactly what I'm talking about. That is
pathetic dormat Christianity which was
created just to destroy Christianity.
And I hope you're not a participant of
this though you may be and you have to
ask yourself okay and stick stick around
and watch my forthcoming streams and
videos because this is one of the topics
that I definitely mean to elaborate on
in the coming weeks and months. Okay. So
my final thoughts is dormat Christianity
is a real thing. It's the one that is
being upheld by society, by the world,
by the devil because it actually helps
them attain what they want to attain,
which is the destruction of Christianity
and free reign for them. Historically,
it wasn't like that. Christians actually
were were right there in the right there
in the trenches fighting evil in
whichever way it was. Okay.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous